now to a disturbing report from the
Secret Service the agency says American
schools are still not doing enough to
identify at-risk students to keep others
safe from school shootings the agency
which protects the president unveiled
what it calls the most in-depth analysis
of school shootings in decades it
studied more than 40 attacks over about
ten years
Jeff McGee's reports the findings alarms
and lockdown procedures to protect
students but according to the report
only 17% of schools where an attack took
place at a system to report concerning
students early intervention is key Lena
al Atari is the chief of the secret
services national threat assessment
Center was there one common denominator
there is no one profile of a student
attacker they varied in terms of ages
backgrounds social diversity academic
performance but there are red flags a
majority of the time the motive for the
attack was a grievance involving a peer
usually related to bullying and 77
percent of attackers threatened their
targets or shared their intentions to
carry out an attack every single student
attacker exhibited a concerning behavior
according to the report there was only
one significant action like calling the
police
taken in fewer than half of the
instances where there was concerning
behavior
Mary Ellen O'Toole a retired FBI
profiler says it's an evolutionary
process there could be days weeks months
and many times it's years where the
shooter is thinking about carrying out
an act of violence we have to do as a
society come together to find solutions
to prevent these attacks tonymont Altos
daughter Gina died with more than a
dozen other students inside their
parkland Florida high school had the
threat assessment on the shooter been
done properly there's an excellent
chance that my lovely daughter and the
16 other wonderful souls that were taken
that days would still be here today the
methodology used in this report is
similar cut to the kind of threat
analysis that the Secret Service uses
to assess threats against public
officials like the president Gale
alright Jeff that's very important
information there it's interesting to
note that there are warning signs that
we could all pay attention
they've just they've discovered there
are patterns in all these cases that
that that send out as you say warning
signs
everybody flags very good information
there